[Music]
all right
people here we are does America still
exist I think it still exists I don't
have a TV in this room Donald Trump is
now the 45th president of the United
States in case you didn't hear about
that uh half the country is going
completely insane the other half seems
very excited that'll constantly be
flipping over the course of the next
four years um we got a a crazy time upon
us and I didn't want to bore you guys
you know you go watch watch CNN you
watch uh Fox News MSNBC C-SPAN and see
the same old people who got everything
wrong the entire way over the course of
the last three years right you can watch
that or I thought I'd bring on some
people that actually did offer me some
insight over the last couple years and
that we also in on it on the alternative
news side because this obviously is the
future I mean the whole thing with Trump
obviously is that mainstream media is
crumbling online media is growing nobody
trusts these institutions anymore and
it's by their own doing and people do
trust or are now at least learning that
there are some alternative voices out
there that are trying to bring some good
stuff so I'm very excited because we
have invested in some new equipment over
here and we're doing our first ever live
group Skype situation for inauguration
day and I am joined today by two at the
moment of my favorite YouTubers we got a
third one coming in a little bit but
first up we have that guy T over in
Atlanta T what's going
on sup how's it going there he is and
direct from Los Angeles but a little bit
that way we've got Chris Ray Gun Chris
how are you hey pretty good pretty good
all right so Blair white is supposed to
be joining us as well but apparently up
north in California there's a big storm
she has no power but we're working on
that so I'm going to start with you guys
so I'm going to need your a games
because you know Blair's pretty good and
I need you guys to step
up yeah we lost so many impression
points you know
sucks all right T I'm gonna start with
you because you're a limited government
guy uh clearly wasn't a a CL a Clinton
guy I don't think you voted for Trump
did you I didn't you did not vote for
Trump are you at Liberty to say who you
voted
before um I actually didn't vote this
year um I was I was I was on the fence
about maybe voting for Trump but in the
end it just I wasn't interested in his
policies enough to warn it and it was
just too much of a hassle so I just I
just bought AR-15
lowers now when I had you guys both on
for YouTube week t i at the time was
trying to push you a little bit to Gary
Johnson even though I said you know the
guy's not a great libertarian all that
stuff so you didn't even want to throw
him your vote huh well Gary Johnson
Still Remains to this day the only
President I've ever voted for um he was
my first vote in um the
201 uh 12 election um but this year
round yeah he just he just wasn't up to
par for me and I just I just couldn't
give it to him yeah now Chris you are a
New York transplant just made it to
California I don't even know that you
would even had time to register did did
you vote nah I didn't I didn't vote at
all I I uh I also didn't have time to
register that was partially the reason
but also neither candidate was one that
I would have ever considered putting my
name behind right did you at least do a
nice little jingle about not
voting h no that that didn't seem worth
it this whole thing was just a mess yeah
so let's talk about the mess part
because I think you guys were kind of
seeing some that a lot of people
started seeing over the last year and a
half you know Chris you really were
nailing this social justice stuff this
split on the left left stuff it doesn't
make you part of the right but just that
something is so freaking broken when did
you wake up to that stuff oh that was uh
probably like 2014 it was probably
around that time where I just started to
notice that uh the people that I had
typically agreed with uh started getting
a
bit zealous is the word I guess a little
bit a little bit uh weirdly religious
about politics like to the point where
they wouldn't they wouldn't be willing
to hear alternative perspectives even if
they slightly differed from their own I
was like ah this is this is starting to
be a little uncomfortable yeah does it
seem obvious to you guys now like
thinking back now after everything that
I learned over the last couple years
talking to people whether I agreed with
them are not like Milo and cernovich and
Scott Adams all these people that were
talking about what was happening with
Trump all the uh the momentum you could
see on Twitter and online all that
doesn't it kind of seem obvious that
this was the result T I'll kick that to
you um that Trump's victory was the
result
yeah yeah I mean at this point you know
if he didn't get the um nomination it
could have it could have gone either way
or even if Clinton didn't get the
nomination they could have gone you know
who knows what the outcome could have
been but with these two combined you
know with the general um social status
we find ourselves in culturally um yeah
there there was no other way like I
think I think well the thing
is like you feel like that Trump's
Victory would have been inevitable but
the guy is just so crazy you know just
you just couldn't fathom it like I I
honestly couldn't fathom him beating
Hillary um but yeah it happened me magic
made it
happen I'm curious how did you guys like
guttery feel like in your gut as you
were watching this thing today because I
kind of felt there were it was like
going like this like I was kind of like
all right there's something good here
America's coming back we're going to
focus on the right things get the
economy going and then there's
definitely and obviously this very
authoritarian streak with him and there
is a little bit of that America First
stuff that sounds like uh the first
order in the force awakens so like I'm
still 50/50 on this whole thing Chris
yeah I mean I I felt the same way I did
on Election Day which was uh I just kind
of found it so immensely funny that this
is it just feels like a a whole joke and
in in some ways it kind of is but uh
yeah I I I don't feel particularly
stressed out or like particularly like
uh I'm not under any illusion that the
world's coming to an end or that oh
everything's going to be perfect now you
know it's it's just it's the same craft
that we've dealt with for a long time
it's just so happens that this candidate
is uh the type of candidate that we
haven't seen either in forever or for a
very very long time what do you think
about his color today I thought the
orange was just about right yeah I guess
T I should kick that to you he looked
pretty he pretty he looked the
appropriate amount of
orange yeah they definitely put you
definitely put in work on it and um and
the the um well it's not new but some I
did realize something today um I found
out that he doesn't wear Trump suits he
wears the um was it Bion suits that he
um I thought he just wore his own line
is that a trump tie at
least uh the tie is probably Trump TI is
probably it's the it's the one made in
America Trump tie yeah why does he keep
that tie so low you see that thing hangs
below his balls what is that
that I don't know I don't I don't know
who dresses it's a status it's a status
symbol that's a status symbol low tie
really the ties that uh touch your
shoes yeah the longer the tie hangs let
you know what's going on ladies do you
guys think this was kind of a win like
to me the win about Trump was that this
was actually a blow to the sjw biger
crowd like they're freaking out and I
think all of us would agree that these
guys needed a loss like if Clinton had
won it would have just tightened those
screws that much more so in that way I
think there's a win now what Trump's
going to do we don't know but just in
that battle the sjw thing what do you
think
T yeah um the um the sjws are are like
you said going crazy um I remember
Lawrence Southern tweeted out earlier
that they were um they were smashing
windows and I saw pictures of some other
cities where um some um ancoms and anti
um black and red Communists were running
around smashing up a Wells Fargo and you
know they had to deploy tear gas and
stuff and those are the really really
far extreme sjws the U more Normie you
know regular Milo um you know Stewart or
you know regular feminists on YouTube
type sjws but they're upset too and I do
think that their loss was um necessary
and I know this is bias coming from
someone who's um pretty far right but um
yeah the the way they've been going
about things their tactics their
rhetoric um and most of all in my
opinion their um General
authoritarianism in their execution of
their you know proposed policies I think
that it was pretty necessary that they
um weren't allowed to be victorious as
um as you know crazy as that sounds but
we are in the r of politics so it's it's
either win or lose here um and I I hope
that this loss will shake them up and
get them to you know rethink um their
position and rethink how they've gone
about doing things but you know I'm not
too hopeful for that we we've we've uh I
mean we've already seen that they
haven't learned any lessons from this
they're still kind of uh parading around
the same talking points that they
paraded uh before the election it I
don't think it's going to amount to much
I think the win with Trump was really
just a win for like oh hey even Hillary
Clinton the person with probably the
most political power the most money
backing her even she could lose the
presidency if enough people came
together and voted for somebody whether
or not that person was the right person
for the job I think it was I think it's
nice to see that it's not always
predetermined like we sometimes might
feel it ish you know what I mean isn't
that the greatest thing about America I
mean to me that's the biggest takeaway
that the media the Power the elite all
the money everything wanted one thing to
happen and the other thing happened like
that's pretty
spectacular it's pretty cool I wish uh I
wish it was a different guy but uh you
know yeah right would have been
awesome hey T what do you think when
when you see all these people rioting
and the tear gas and throwing in
Bank windows and all that stuff you know
these are these are your guys in a way
the the anarchists right no no do not
let me correct me
the anarco capitalists are sophisticated
we're not degenerate we are not involved
with these type of people but um yeah
you know I feel like especially with the
victory of trump there's always there's
forever you know there's always been
this pretty anti- capitalist sentiment
on the left and um as the sjw and the
cultural Marxism is growing up and kind
of exploded recently and um terms social
media it's kind of like stirred the pile
a little bit and like kind of like took
it to the next level where like they
feel embolden like yeah capitalism is a
problem let's go ahead and really smash
it this time um
but you know I I feel like Trump's
Victory is it's a win for not even
really a win but it it lets you know
that at least the reaction lets you know
that there is something about to come in
which the opposition to capitalism and
the um furthering of capitalism is going
to try is going to clash and um whether
that Clash is going to result in
productive communication and trying to
actually solve problems and how we can
work forward or whether we um
accidentally Go full penet you know I
don't know but we'll definitely have to
see so is that that's basically the the
screwy situation that we're in that
these people who think the whole
system's against them now they've got
the easiest giant orange blob to say you
see the system is against us and then he
will have to turn the system against
them so I don't see a lot of opportunity
for for these people to come together I
think there's some new center developing
but it has almost nothing to do with
these
guys yeah yeah um I wouldn't
disagree yeah I would agree too um sorry
Chris you can go ahead no that's that's
fine I'm just saying no it makes sense I
mean I'm just watching Twitter go insane
yeah yeah actually you know what we'll
take some questions from Twitter so uh
tweet at the three of us or tweet at me
or whatever it is we'll take some
questions from Twitter and from the
YouTube comments as well um Chris do you
ever think that if the sjw thing gets
smashed like let's say Trump somehow
just blows the whole thing apart and
it's over you got to change
careers me nah n i I've uh
facilitated uh an audience that seems to
be willing to deal with whatever
I'm I'm willing to put up on
screen I think what what I do is more
kind of like I I built a channel off of
just whatever whatever I felt like
talking about it's not necessarily uh
entirely social justice related it it
happened to be because it was
particularly interesting this past uh
year and a half but I'm not I'm not
worried yeah do you think it's over on
the left for guys like us you know I've
been saying it for the last couple weeks
that maybe we did lose here like maybe I
do really have to be like I'm not on the
right in a traditional sense but the the
left thing do you think maybe we
actually did lose
that I I don't know I feel like again I
feel like the the labels are kind of
meaningless now I don't think we've lost
it so much as like the game that we're
playing is just old and boring and
obsolete it's like you don't you don't
have to lose to um to just stop playing
you know what I mean it's
um the it labels in and of themselves
are like worthless now like who when was
the last time you spoke to somebody and
asked and asked the question oh hey are
you
left you know like it doesn't I know I
say it on the show every week it's like
I hate these freaking labels and yet
sometimes you need them just because
otherwise people just don't know what
the hell you're talking
about yeah I yeah it's it's a good
um it's a good uh What do you call it a
good um ice breaker I guess or not even
like an icebreaker more of like a a
really digestive
small bite-sized version of what you
might think like I would say that I'm
still liberal you know because I think
it's most accurate to what I what I
would personally agree with uh as far as
the stereotypical liberal goes but even
so it's like those things don't Define
absolutely everything and even even
within the realm of politics they don't
they don't Define everything within the
realm of politics and they certainly
don't Define anything outside of it so
yeah hey T since I know what you hate
more than anything is
authoritarianism the Trump thing is kind
of interesting for someone like you
because on one hand he's going to
probably lower corporate taxes
businesses will start doing stuff again
on the other hand he's got all this
America First stuff so you know if you
want to buy things from other countries
or if businesses want to move freely and
lay a fair capitalism and all that he's
he's not going to be good for that
right yeah definitely not definitely not
so much and U even though even though
recently his um his
his um execution of protectionism has
been a little bit different than I
expected um seeing as he's he's going
the route of you know trying to more so
persuade companies um to to stay in
America by you know offering them lower
taxes or you know this this perk or that
perk or that benefit things like that or
um or or this you know press coverage
you know I mean I'm sure all any company
with bad PR right now that they're
they're dying to say ah yeah we just
made a deal with Trump to keep a
thousand jobs um right even though even
though that is still in its nature um
crony capitalist um and I would I would
prefer it to be a complete um free
market system with with just um General
free market
competition but you know we're in this
situation where you know neither side is
really on board with that so I don't
know um I mean it seems like he's making
the best out of what he of what he can
and hopefully he he keeps it like that
and not go the route of trying to
actually penalize company
um who do go outside of outside of his
you know vision for America but um yeah
his his authoritarianism it's a it's an
interesting breed that we haven't seen
in a while um and I'm interesting to see
how it's G to play out right because I
guess it's that the idea of America
first that's not a philosophy it's not
an economic philosophy really so he
could say America First meaning I want
everyone to buy American but if you want
goods to be traded freely and equally
cross borders not great for
you yeah definitely um you know Trump
like like like you said kindless times
in your video Trump is a populist he
wants he wants to um you know have a
Mass Appeal to the people he wants to H
he wants his legacy I don't know if he
actually wanted it before or if it just
ended up because it was his campaign
slogan um to make America great again
you know and how he's going to go about
that you know we'll have we'll have to
see um I'm definitely not too thrilled
about all of his um of his proposals and
his ideas and I think some of them
actually won't even work um hope
hopefully we have the wall out of our
systems at this point but I I I feel
like you know being someone who is
interested in economics I don't I don't
I hate actually saying this but I do I
do agree that I feel like the the
primary point of Trump's Victory and the
primary thing that people are going to
be looking forward to including myself
actually is going to be the culture
shift and um how he how he changes the
um the framework of American culture as
it is now rather than just you know
economics and um you know Health Care
policies and you know things like that
yeah I'm with you on that and we've
already had a crazy culture shift going
on right now right like I've been
tweeting lately about how Comics I mean
you famous Comics that are a lot more
successful and have a lot more M than I
do these have people have become
painfully unfunny I mean major stars and
and producers and what Chris what do you
think about that as a guy that goes to
the funny because I think your goal
usually is to make people laugh and if
there's a point in there that's great
but what do you think about like all
these people that are just having
endless nervous breakdowns right
now it's uh it's depressing especially
because a lot of them are people that I
previously like really enjoyed even if
it's like people like Pat and Oswalt
like telling people to hoard food and it
just it reminds me of back when Obama
was elected and and people in Texas were
like we're gonna secede it's like
everybody just needs to calm down it's
it's another president he doesn't agree
with you deal with it like people who
haven't agreed with Obama have dealt
with it for the last eight years and
we're fine yeah like you'll be totally
comedians winning with comedy wouldn't
that be the way you beat the guy instead
of telling everybody to hoard food and
trying to censor Milo's book and the
rest of this yeah the the
interesting thing that I found about
comedy especially in regards to Trump
which was I I felt really disappointed
when Trump won specifically on one
stance because it's difficult to be
funny when you're making fun of trump
because it's just
so boring and it's everything that you
could say about him has been set already
and it's cool you know it's like back in
when Hillary was a serious candidate
like people like you and me people like
T I'm sure every everybody in our Circle
we were kind of the only people on on
YouTube that I saw who were really
taking any Jabs at Hillary Clinton but
now everyone is taking Jabs at Trump so
you can't even really be funny about it
you kind of have to be genuinely serious
about it and be like okay so this is the
actual problem with Trump I can't beat
around the bush here I can't make a joke
here because that's the only way you're
going to say something new because
stupid I hate to say it but Milo
called that a year and a half ago
on my show I mean Milo was saying that
there's nothing funny left on the left
and it's all become this preachy
nonsense and yeah he's pretty much right
yeah I mean Hillary was uh infinitely
funnier I think with her uh her in
random spasms and
her there was so much material to work
off of
uh that I feel like Trump is like oh
he's
Orange it's awful we got to the point
where we're we're laughing at
seizures I would like to question I have
a I have a deranged sense of humor I
think a lot of things are funny that
probably aren't but uh I don't know
Hillary was just a meme machine and
Donald Trump is a meme machine also but
like it's a very different kind of
machine it is a different kind of
machine so let's talk about big machine
here right now which I think one thing
that we definitely all would agree on is
that the destruction of the mainstream
media has kind of been a beautiful thing
over the last year right yeah yes I mean
the mainstream media has been under uh
under attack for quite a while like I I
haven't watched CNN or or fox in like
like SE seven years really yeah so I'm
glad that it's kind of catching
up do you think there's a risk though
that anybody can do what we're doing I
mean I'm not even professing that the
three of us are the greatest experts on
anything I think you know all three of
us have a unique perspective and I think
these days that's more important than
anything else but that anyone can get on
YouTube sit at a desk put on a suit and
pretend they know what they're talking
about there's some risk in there
right I would um I would say so you know
but it it's it's a it's a it's a
worthwhile risk I would say as well um
because go going forward you know at
least that's what I wanted to see coming
out of this whole um election ordeal you
know the the revisiting um of
communication you know trying to
actually you know put forth ideas and
getting people to actually propose what
they think and trying to talk Solutions
and PE people always say you know oh we
always do that we're always talking
Solutions when in reality most most most
of the time at least from what I see
people um are usually just critical and
being critical and proposing you know
fresh original ideas are not the same
thing um and I think one is immensely
more valuable than the other
so I I with with this wave of people
coming on to the scene um with with
these fresh new ideas some some like
completely completely um you know um
brand new like the um 36 genders and
stuff like that and some you know
revisiting the um the good old days you
know trying just repackaged some stuff a
little bit you know kind of like um you
know our alt-right buddies and you know
saying you know uh the um Third Reich
wasn't wasn't so bad I mean they had
they had awesome they had awesome suits
you have to admit um but but but even
with all this stuff you know I I just
want people to actually just put forth
ideas and not so much just criticize
what's already out there but go going
forward try and create something new
because I think that's how we're going
to progress yeah I mean that's actually
why you know when I was railing against
the aggressive left for year I've tried
to shift a little bit away from that CU
at some point we made our point you know
enough people like you guys and a whole
bunch of other YouTubers we all started
hitting the same thing and I think it
got to a little bit of critical mass
maybe it had a tiny bit to do with what
happened with this election and now it's
like well how do we actually change
things not just about
everything yeah and um I I would like to
see that too and I'm wondering too uh
speaking of like the whole um production
scene and since both of you are in like
kind of like the media content Capital
um in La uh do you guys see anything
changing um in regards to the um like
people getting ready for for Trump's
presidency because I know leading up to
it um you know everyone was going really
hard against Trump and really going
really hard for Clinton and once he lost
there was like this crushing defeat and
like everything just like went silent
for a while and you know nobody
everybody was just like real low energy
and just depressed and no no you know
the media was frantically trying to you
know maintain credibility and they
failed in that tremendously which was
amazing to see but do you guys see um
anything coming forward like what people
are like getting ready for the fight
rather um in terms of like the media
sense Chris I'll let you go
first well you know Patton oswalt's
getting people to hoard
food that's a good that's a good
preparation no I I haven't noticed a
particular change in Attitude I've it's
it's always been kind of it's been salty
since since uh the election was lost but
yeah I haven't noticed much of any
change I mean Dave's more into this
whole media thing than I am I I just
make crap in my
room well I'm in my basement uh basement
I'm in my garage for the record but uh I
would say yeah I've seen something shift
because you guys know this everybody
wants clicks and Views and likes and all
that stuff and as the mainstream has
just watched people just Purge and just
disappear from their numbers and seeing
what's actually happening here they're
going to adjust um and I was I was in
New York last week and I had some
meetings with some networks and agencies
and things like that and basically
everybody was like after inauguration
it's a new game because we've hired a
lot of people over the course of the
election they Babble on about what they
get wrong they get all their stats wrong
and their polls wrong and they're the
same sold out people everyone's been
listening to and now there's some other
good going on so I think I think
we're g to see something major on the
media front this year well even um
wasn't uh I I kept hearing a lot about
Megan Kelly apparently moving to uh was
it NBC NBC yeah that's a pretty big move
that probably wouldn't have happened a
year ago I couldn't see that happening
under an Obama presidency like somebody
from Fox News just like hey yeah come on
yeah it's fine can you guys imagine
walking from 20 million Fox offered her
20 million a year and she walked I I
don't believe that I I I can't believe
that number I just can't that's that's
an insane I I I don't believe that
number either that's that's far too
that's insane that's more than uh I feel
like most hit TV stars make per episode
you think we got I think I feel like if
we put on some of her outfits we could
pull those numbers it's about showing
arm I think it's it's the legs even even
though you can't see it you know it's
just just that's the fox thing you know
you know that there's some awesome legs
underneath that desk and it's just the
fact that you just know there it's there
it's worth million we gotta get uh it's
a shame we don't have Blair here to
offer some insight I know all right so
we're gonna we're gonna find out what's
up with Blair but meanwhile I got a
whole bunch of people asking questions
for you guys uh so Chris first one's for
you uh what do you think's going to
emerge in punk music for the next eight
years uh they didn't they have a lot of
material to say about Obama but they
didn't that's a good one yeah so so I
mean I did um I did a couple videos on
on particularly horrible anti-hillary
songs and they weren't bad because they
were anti-hillary I love uh all sorts of
political music uh Punk music's my
favorite and that's a notoriously
liberal genre like Rise Against is one
of my favorites and they're remarkably
liberal um
but I feel like um again because it's so
cool to criticize Trump because it's
like oh it's something that your parents
can do on Facebook and everyone's fine
with it I feel like that kind of takes a
little bit of the edge off of punk and
even just any political uh music that
you would want to make so I feel like
what we're going to see in music in
general as we saw with the most latest
uh the most recent gilla's track is that
we're just going to get a lot of uh
heavy-handed preaching that doesn't
sound particularly good at all and it's
a shame yeah well hopefully it doesn't
fully go down that route uh first off
someone just jumped on and said that
they'll join me on patreon if I dress
like Megan Kelly so uh please hold for
that um oh a couple people ask about
this what do you guys think of the
religious stuff today like first off
Trump talking about
God I have no reason to believe this guy
believes in God or even cares about God
in any way his worst moment of the whole
campaign was at Liberty University when
he's trying to quote Corinthians
whatever and he's dripping with sweat
meanwhile the Christian conservatives
voted for him at like 90% but then right
after you know they had the rabbi come
out and Billy Graham and I mean it
seemed like a joke right they walking
into a bar um you know I think all that
stuff is basically I would much
rather have the president not put his
hand on a Bible we're not governed by
the Bible we're governed by the
Constitution so I would much rather have
him hand his hand on the on the
Constitution what do you think about all
the religious stuff
T I mean yeah it's it's it's mainly
devolved into Tradition at this point um
I don't believe Trump is um you know at
all nearly religious I'm pretty sure
he's agnostic if not you know full-blown
like just completely um a religious in
general um
but the thing is you know even though
even though personally I'm an atheist
if I was religious I I would I would
understand the significance of um like
the selfish significance of having I'm a
president um swear in in regards to the
Bible and then having all the different
religious leaders come out and you know
because um and even even though I'm
particularly a big fan of the whole
swearing on the Bible thing I still do
appreciate um bringing out the religious
leaders and having them you know do
their little um you know uh you know In
God We Trust speech Just because um
there's I don't I don't know how strong
it is now but there is still this lying
you know backdrop
where uh if if if anything can still
bring people together you know even even
on the on the um left if um or on the
right or whatever if it's something that
can still not necessarily bring the two
people together bring their own
individual collectives together um in
you know solidarity of you know values
like peace and um you know hospitality
and things like that it it unfortunately
it still um relegates to religion um and
there's a lot of religious people who
you know may be going crazy right now um
in opposition to Trump you know thinking
he's a racist a sexist you know and
islamophobe and whatever and when they
um but when they have these religious
leaders come out you know it's still it
it it guesss it like kind of like calms
those Waters I would think that would be
the purpose um and I would hope it'll be
successful in that um even though I
noticed that they didn't bring out um
any um Muslim leaders I'm pretty sure
that wouldn't fly especially with Trump
um but yeah that was interesting I
thought I saw yesterday though they were
gonna bring out an Imam but I guess he
didn't show or I don't know what
happened oh I didn't I didn't know they
were considering bringing one out but um
yeah they just had the um I'm sorry for
any religious people um I don't know
their names but the Jewish guy the
Catholic guy and the um the pimp pastor
with the purple shirt so yeah you've
really offended some sensibilities there
by not knowing the rabbi and the
priest's
name oh man Chris what do you think
about the religious stuff I I get T I
get what you're saying that everything's
so crazy that you hear some people talk
about God and peace and maybe that's
nice I just see no use for it in
government it has nothing to do with
reality really but I I get your point
Chris what do you think yeah I mean uh
it's funny I tweeted uh because I was
having fun on Twitter with during the
whole inauguration thing and I said I I
I've been just tweeting these snide
remarks I said stop stop trying to make
religion a thing and it pissed off a lot
of PE a lot of people so it kind of
makes me happy to know that those people
are still around to offend because I
feel like they've been gone for ages so
it's nice to see kind of like seeing an
old ugly friend you know yeah you what
do you guys think of the people that
outraged constantly like forgetting just
the politics behind them just like the
type of person that's just waiting just
waiting for Chris Ray Gun to say one
thing they don't like and they're going
to tumbler the out of that thing
well they'll they'll do it because
here's the thing it's it's it's always
okay as long as uh the sensibilities
that I don't personally identify with
are the subject of jokes that's what
I've noticed it's like uh uh yeah I mean
if you're following me on Twitter and
for some reason forgot that I was a
liberal there you
go like I'm going to make fun fun of
religion like there's no there's no
topic that's off the table in my mind
it's it's it's all this whole thing is a
big joke and it's fun to treat it as if
it is and uh you know just learn to
laugh have some fun I I couldn't agree
more a whole bunch of people are asking
about the speech itself uh basically a
lot of people are saying that it was
really aggressive and like it didn't
really seem like it was trying to heal
anything T what do you think about
that it was uh yeah I mean it was it
definitely wasn't a Kon bayas speech um
but you know it it honestly wasn't
really that um impressive of a speech
for me personally it it was it was what
we've heard from him you know throughout
his entire campaign um you know that
we're going to you know make America
great again we're gonna bring back jobs
we're gonna build the roads and you know
the average politician stuff um and you
know that that that's I I feel like
that's Trump's thing um you know he's
he's either just fullblown boring
average you know talking points or he's
crazy extraordinaire meme guy um those
are like his two personalities always
one extreme or the other um but you know
it he had to pick one um I'm pretty sure
the latter would have been um funnier
for his speech but he went with he went
with normal guy um you know rallying off
his campaign slogans and um his his um
you know proposed policies that he that
we've heard a million times s so the
speech wasn't really you know that crazy
for me you know it did it didn't make me
feel like like you know I wasn't I
wasn't impressed I wasn't um enamored by
it or anything and
it it didn't seem passionate to me um
and I I don't know if that's just
Trump's demeanor but um for some reason
I don't I don't really get this sense of
passion from him that much um at Le at
least not in the whole you know overly
emotional cartoony way he he may just be
a really laidback guy for all I know but
yeah the speech wasn't all that for me
do those buzzword when they saying you
know he's racist or he's homophobic or
islamophobic any of that stuff I mean I
know what you guys think of all those
buzzwords but Chris do you think any of
them are actually uh applicable to him
do you think he actually doesn't like
black people or doesn't like gay people
or any of that
stuff now no I don't think so I think I
think Trump is a very malleable person I
like like what what have been his
politics for the last 20 years you know
I I feel like they've been like
veryable yeah they've just been whatever
fits the circumstance I I feel like he's
more um
narcissistic than he is any of those
other buzzwords like I I feel like it's
not that Trump doesn't care about black
people or Trump doesn't care about gay
people it's that Trump cares about
himself and maybe other rich people
people maybe if he likes them so I don't
know I uh I don't buy the buzzwords but
I do think he's a pretty self-indulgent
dude who's probably not going to have
too many people's best interest in mind
at the end of the day that's really
that's my I'm curious did you guys see
on Twitter I saw that Sea King had
tweeted something about you know 13 of
the 16 people or white men in the
cabinet or something and I tweeted back
at him and I said you know shouldn't you
care more about the cont of their
character than the color of their skin I
guess that's not really cool these days
you know it was more of a popul
sentiment like 40 years ago um first
you're not blocked by Shan King what's
that you're not blocked by Shan King I'm
not blocked as far as I know you yeah I
am are you guys both blocked by him I'm
checking right now I am you're blocked
by him no I'm not I am not blocked by
Sean you guys need step game man yeah
Chris we'll see what we can do with that
I think by the end of this conversation
we might get there
um privilege yeah I'm curious what you
both think on this though because I saw
him tweet that you know this thing about
13 of the 16 people are white and then
the same day I saw Mark Lamont Hill
who's one of these guys who runs around
CNN and all these things and he was
addressing the fact that there are some
black people around Trump and supporting
Trump and in the cabinet and all that
and he called them mediocre Negroes and
I thought man this just captures the
whole thing if he has white people then
he's a white supremacist if he has black
people then then they're somehow
sellouts like this is just the this is
the uh it's the Pinnacle of lazy
thinking uh T you
first yeah um I saw that um Zack tweet
that you um or not the Tweet but the
quote that somebody tweeted at me that
you mentioned and somebody um replied to
me they said okay I wonder how long
until um the same guy is going to start
complaining about you know
underrepresentation in Trump's cabinet
from black people you know after he just
labeled everyone trying to get involved
mediocre blacks um it it's it's so
ridiculous and um and it m it makes you
think like what what's even the point of
of trying to of trying to please them
you know like like like at this point
it's like whatever you're gonna be mad
fine be mad we're over here making
America great again and I feel like that
that overall is the one sentiment that
resonates with people um that you know
is it there there's always you know
every election cycle or in regard to
politics anyway you know there's always
this idea of you know the desire to come
together and work together and everyone
you know compromise and you know um you
know just just try to get something done
and stuff like that um around both sides
bipartisanly and now people um you know
are getting to the point where you know
there there's just there's both there's
sides um both on the left and the right
majority on the left at the moment where
they're just not willing to compromise
and you know we we could constantly sit
here Walling off fingers saying you know
come on guys you know Kumbaya come on
let's work together or we can just say
how about how about we just we just do
our own things and try to be successful
in that and I I think that's what a lot
of people are doing now and you know if
if um Mark Lamont sees you know black
people trying to work with Trump as
being mediocre um that's fine but you
know if if he I I wish him luck in what
he's doing and I just hope that he
doesn't get in the way of um other black
people who actually are trying to be
productive yeah I mean that's the part
that gets me because you take a guy like
Steve Harvey Trump meets the guy this is
an extremely successful guy virtually
Everyone likes Steve Harvey I don't know
there's a lot of people walking around
going I don't like Steve Harvey right
and it's like he's going to try to do
something he's G to try to work on the
inner cities that's what everyone's
wanted for so long so if you're going to
pin him as a sellout it's like I agree
with you then it's like everyone's going
to be like all right this there's
nothing I can do to win so I'm going to
do whatever I want to do Chris I'm
curious you are a Latino or is it Latin
x what do you prefer I don't know I
don't know what the hell I don't care
but I am I am of Puerto Rican blood yes
all right so you are of Puerto Rican
blood I didn't notice a lot of Latinos
on the uh in the cabinet are you upset
by this no no I I am so apathetic to
Chris can't you get upset by anything
come on for God's sakes dude I feel like
I'm just so numb to it it's like again
like we were just talking about how
um how like no matter no matter what
Trump does he can't win like Trump could
go outside and talk about oh hey the
sky's pretty blue isn't it and there'd
be a whole hashtag campaign about how it
absolutely
isn't and it's just he's such a cartoon
character at this point or or like he's
he's been built into to such this
Saturday morning villain that like I
can't I can't care I've tried I've tried
so hard to care but like the the
representation in the cabinet uh for me
I mean there's barely any uh Latino um
AAA movie stars or particular like Linn
Manuel Miranda might be the uh the most
prevalent um Puerto Rican uh music
person like a person in the music
industry but and you know the
representation has always been lacking
but it's like it's it's never been I
don't
view somebody who has the color of my
skin or has the Heritage that I have as
any more um capable of dictating the the
laws of the land as anybody else it
doesn't seem to because it doesn't
affect me at all like like I I don't
base my decisions on whether or not
somebody else shares my Heritage or not
so why would why would a Supreme Court
Justice or a Cabinet member do the same
isn't that also just like a a huge shell
game like I had Margaret Cho in here and
I was questioning her because she
definitely falls into a lot of the sjw
stuff and I was happy to have her here
and treated as respectfully as I treat
anybody else but I was trying to show
her that in a lot of ways you could
argue the Asian community in America has
done it better than anybody because all
they cared about not all they cared
about but they've put a tremendous
emphasis on education and work and
family and through that have huge
economic success have great jobs uh live
in good communities upper middle class
etc etc and what I was trying to say to
her is well maybe there isn't that much
representation in movies but in a weird
way maybe it's because they kept their
eye on the ball I I don't think she
fully got what I was saying but that
seems to me to be the way to do it it's
it's uh feasible I um I
mean it's all uh it it all seems to be
very surface level um analysis like oh
this guy's black so he he'll be good for
black people like no it's not it's not
always the case T what's it like having
a walk around representing all black
people all the time must be
exhausting it's it's a burden um you
know but I I just try my best not to get
arrested and not get shot and I think I
think that's a pretty good you know I
think I'm doing a good job yeah well I'm
curious what are you like your family
and your friends cuz your politics are
pretty they're pretty out there for
getting left right or any of that
but you're you're stuff and
you're very outspoken I mean what do the
people around you think about you
putting your voice out
there um actually you know they they've
been pretty supportive um you know most
most of my family and most most people
around me in my U General Community are
um pretty pretty far left um but Mo most
people at least my family in my
community and I think most people in
general are you know kind of apolitical
you know they they have their
preferences here and there they um they
they you know they buy into the
mainstream news stuff so of course they
think Trump is racist and bigot and
stuff like that but it you know overall
I I think I think like it's it's not
really as a big of um a concern for them
as a lot of people may think um I think
there's very few people um in America
overall that really care that much about
um about like you know actually getting
involved in trying to like shape
politics um I think most people just you
know play their um not play their card
but um put in put in their vote the
ballot every every four years and just
say all right we'll see what happens um
but as far as my um what I've gotten
back from My Views um it's been pretty
pretty positive um most people are um
supportive of me I've had quite a few
people um disagree but um it's a
respectful disagreement you know it's
not it's not what I what I anticipated
where I thought I would get like shunned
from the community and you know um call
a sellout and stuff you know that's more
that's more so from um the most who the
people who claim to be the most tolerant
of people um those are the ones who are
most likely to shun me out um but you
know it's been it's been okay yeah Chris
speaking of Tolerance you tweeted
something funny or I saw a video on or
something uh that somebody was calling
you a white supremacist you live with
like three black guys know you yeah yeah
all my roommates are are black dudes and
they've been my friends since like high
school they're really cool guys uh and
they know what I do and they know that
they don't they don't care but like
you're really getting in deep with the
white supremacist Community infiltrating
obviously yeah I'm I'm a I'm a spy you
ever play Splinter Cell that's me dude
I'm infiltrating
but a couple people a couple people have
asking what what do we think that
Michelle and Barack were thinking that
whole time because did you guys see I
mean Michelle had the cold stare of
death the whole day I mean from when she
was walking down with ianka to when she
when Trump was walking by and Trump
didn't shake her hand at the end I don't
know if you saw that um I think I mean
the whole speech really seemed like like
a big like screw you to Obama like
you've divided us and I'm going to unite
us I got to say since the election from
from the day after the election I think
Obama has been pretty good on this like
that we have to have a smooth transition
of power I obviously don't like this guy
this is a vision I don't like but like
we have 240 years of history that we got
to follow in so I think he's been okay
but the the speech was kind of rough to
them what do you think they were
thinking I just had with Chris I just
had to laugh at that one no I mean I
think they were they were thinking
Hillary how could you yeah like like you
had one job mess this up so
bad that's actually pretty funny like
they're actually angry rer at Hillary
right now I I I wouldn't be surprised I
mean how do you like how does Hillary
like I I can't even imagine what
Hillary's thinking like when she's just
standing there clapping just like oh my
God I just it's all it's all so amusing
to me yeah but you know she still got
that she still got that fake smile you
know the whole time the whole day she
had her fake smile on which I think is
what a lot of people didn't like about
her in the first place exactly I think I
think honestly if Hillary would have
been just like like laid back and just
like this is with the worst expression
on her face I would I'd be totally like
yeah dude finally yeah like like at
least be honest how it we we all we all
know you're salty like just be real yeah
how could you not how could you not be
that be like livid I mean Bernie Sanders
they their closeups on him he was salty
I saw that he did he didn't hide it but
he he he was salty but he don't they
respect that more if you're genuine
people respect people being genuine
that's why that's why Trump won that's
why Bernie had such a huge lead early on
it's it's because you could tell people
a genuine it's it's obvious it's a
giveaway yeah the is crumbling
at Epic rates huh like I I'm talking
about media politician like everything
like just the General State of
like we all knew something has been
wrong with our whole discourse for a
long time and now it's just seemingly
obvious right oh
yeah yeah I would say so I mean um
it's it's it's such a it's such a weird
um transition going on you know it's
like it's it's not really a a
ideological shift um more so I think
it's like in um I don't want to say an
ideological divide happening but you
know it's it's just um people you know
just um dividing themselves up you know
they're they're they're they're
abandoning the um like just the general
you know Collective they've been in for
so long and I think that's why we're
seeing the rise of so many alternative
voices um you know whether you agree
agree or disagree with them um you know
like for instance um um some someone who
I I I've never would you asked me would
if you would have asked me five years
ago if I would have um you know had an
interest in this guy been like are you
crazy um you're racist but I I've I've
taken immense interest in like someone
like Richard Spencer who's um who who
has extremely controversial views you
know very um very uh what's the word I'm
looking for
um like I can't think of the word small
isolated you know um Niche Niche views
um and he's but he's um like just just
the the difference in in what he's
bringing forward and just the uniqueness
in perspective um it's refreshing and I
I think a lot of people are trying to um
are getting on board with that and I
think I think that comes back to what I
was talking about in regards to like
creation over criticism like people are
actually like bringing forth new ideas
and saying you know how about what about
this you know how about we try this and
how about we propose this you know
instead of just going back and forth
with saying um a little bit of this side
a little bit of that side you know the
same old boring you know um political
jargon that we've heard from forever
yeah that's a tough spot to be in though
CU I I feel like I'm in a little bit of
that like a guy like Richard Spencer
guess what he's not happy that you're in
the country probably not thrilled that
I'm in the actually all three of us
right we got a black guy a Latino and a
Jew he's not thrilled with any of the
three of us but I think we would all
agree that that silencing this guy is
not the
answer yeah yeah I mean it's uh what is
it the the strian effect if you like if
you purposely go out and silence
something it just makes it it more
likely that people are going to find out
what the hell you're trying to silence
in the first place yeah I mean look what
they did with Milo yeah exactly exactly
like censorship uh doesn't help anyone
it it doesn't it doesn't do anything um
yeah but yeah I this this whole thing
has been interesting because like I uh
this might be a bit of a a detour here
but like in my my household has always
been like my my dad's was this is always
has always been this super conservative
dude he was all pro Trump this whole
this whole time watching Fox News every
every damn day and my mom was this uh
very very liberal very very like into
like spiritual healing so I got I got
both sides of the debate from a very
early age which is why now I I just find
myself just so in the middle of
everything I guess that's the answer if
you come from a conservative dad and a
liberal mom you end up doing music about
all this stuff yeah that was cool right
who what happened there what was that
something freaked all right wait you
know what I'm going to do I'm going to
do a quick little reset the questions
have been blowing up in here so keep
throwing questions at us on YouTube I'm
here with that guy T in Atlanta Georgia
I'm here with Chris ray gun in a
slightly different part of Los Angeles
that I'm at and Blair white was supposed
to be joining us but uh apparently
there's a big power outage big there is
a massive storm right now in Northern
Cali so hopefully she can jump in at
some point um let's see here uh all
right here's one do you guys think it'll
be easier to hold the Trump
Administration to account compared to
previous Elite offices that's that's
kind of interesting Chris what do you
think can we hold these guys to
account I think we can but I think
politics again have become so ingrained
in everything and and so uh primary
defining Factor as to whether or not we
even communicate with each other that I
feel like uh a lot of people who either
voted for Trump or supported Trump
vehemently will just not be open to
criticism uh however legitimate it is
and I feel like it would have been the
same uh if Hillary would have won I feel
I feel like we're in a particularly
politically I don't know if this term
makes a lot of sense but it's a very
politically religious time where like
people I I guess like as the west or the
United States in particular has uh
started to kind
of uh sway away from religion even like
the the alt-right is like barely uh what
I would consider Christian
conservative um I feel like as as
religion has kind of Gone Away we've
replaced it with politics so we're just
not all to be bigoted to somebody over
religion but you could be very bigoted
to them over their political beliefs
well it's not even that it's just like
it's it's it's like devout politics like
Trump can do no
wrong
guys uh Hillary can do no wrong guys
really like ah what's what's that about
potential dead reporters ah don't worry
about it don't worry about it oh what
Trump has no uh experience doing
anything ah don't worry about it he's
fine yeah hey T odd did you see my tweet
during this thing that I was saying that
the best argument against progressivism
and what's happened to the left this is
the best example right now of limiting
government because it's not always going
to be your guy in Power so the only way
to really neuter them is that you got to
take the power away from everybody so
when it's your guy he'll have a little
less power that's going to be tough on
you but that way when it goes the other
way unless you want to live under a
fascist dictatorship you got to neuter
that guy is that the best argument for
small
government um I I would hope so you know
um this
um this I don't know it's such a weird
freaking time and um I'm sorry I I
missed a little bit of what you said um
in that one because I was getting a
phone call from Facebook and damn
another you're multitasking over
basically that the the the best argument
for Li limited government what I would
say to my Progressive friends is guys if
you don't like Trump right now if you if
you think that this is going to be this
evil uh dictatorship well then that's an
argument for small government because
it's not always going to be your guy in
charge
yeah I would absolutely agree with
that and um you know I think I think
people are um starting to realize that I
mean I would think that would be an easy
answer for people um to just realize
that you
know I said I said this on um Twitter
the other day um I said you know you
know people um say you know Trump's
anti-science and you know he's um you
know gonna you know never going to have
progress in global warming because of
trump things like that I I said that um
and I I believe it to an extent that
Trump poses no um threat or no direct
threat to the continued Innovations of
science unless you believe that science
is an inherent byproduct of socialism um
because people have this idea that in
order to get something that they believe
should be done done in order to um you
know get whatever type of accomplishment
they want to have happen um they they
need they need government behind them to
do it um when when historically that
hasn't been the case um you know most
most most major Innovations in whether
it be in science or any field for that
matter or socially culturally has come
from not not from having a you know huge
um Power backing you but rather just
having the ability to pursue whatever
you're trying to do having just having
the freedom to get it done and I I think
I think if you continue to you know give
people that freedom and I think if
people actually utilize that freedom I
mean it's possible for them to um to you
know get whatever they want to get done
uh and and it it it um makes that threat
of you know having to worry about you
know whether this person gets in if
they're gonna you know Screw us over or
this person gets in they're gonna screw
us over um it minimizes that threat
because at that point you're no longer
riant on having your guy in office or
having you know your um preferences
realized in government to actually get
your done um so I I would hope
people you know start to realize that
you know we're getting people um in
office you know we got Trump in office
you know whether whether you agree with
him whether you think he's just the
racist um crazy you know anti-science
Hitler um realize that you know now is
the time for you to start you know
trying to figure out ways to get
done on your own you know figure out
ways to get stuff done in an alternative
route than um traditionally you know
just lobbying government to try and get
it done for you yeah but that's my how
do we make Freedom cool again freedom is
supposed to be cool it's the I don't
give a what you guys do in your
lives you know what I mean like I want
you to live your life and I'll live my
life and you know we'll do this every
now and again but why is it that people
think that freedom somehow like young
people it seems to be that they are into
socialism well you mean like they think
that uh your freedom comes explicit
specifically from the government yeah
well that they there's this idea that
younger people are having more and more
socialistic attitudes and if you talk to
them about freedom and individuality
instead of collective and all that they
think that means you're selfish or evil
or some capitalist monster where to me
individual liberty is the greatest thing
you got maybe I think that I think that
attitude comes mostly from just being
again in in a first world nation where
you can kind of think about oh why don't
we just kind of help everyone you know
what I mean it's it's I don't think it's
a particularly
incorrect uh viewpoint but it's a
correct Viewpoint for when you can do it
like I said back a while ago I was
having a conversation similar to this
where I was like oh well so um you don't
think we should help uh foreign
countries rebuild it's like no it's like
that'd be nice but we should
probably focus on ourselves for like you
can't help somebody if you got two
broken legs you know yeah so you work on
fixing yourself first and then you when
you can do that go ahead but I don't
think we're particularly at a point
where we can just uh give free college
to everybody yeah although ironically
that's pretty much what Trump said today
right like America First we're going to
deal with our first and then we'll
go from there hey T A whole bunch of
people are asking is that a real gun
behind you I can't see it where from my
little here I noticed that too yeah yeah
it is it's um it's authentic yeah yeah
what do you got there I can't really see
it can you grab it it's it's a um yeah I
can it is a I want all guests of the
Ruben report to be packing heat for now
on let's see oh man and for anyone who
was wondering yes I do have on gym
shorts I'm I'm I'm only half
professional um it's all that matters
it's a um just a um Pap m85 um AK pistol
D AK pistol hell yeah yeah
little um little Trap House gun Chris
what's the most violent thing you have
in your bedroom oh gez uh probably that
Rosewood
[Laughter]
guitar California is ready you guys are
video game I could see you beating
people with a guitar yeah I wouldn't
mind that' be that'd be awesome somebody
make that game somebody already made a
game where I'm a playable character but
I'm spraying bleach out of a bottle
thank thank you for that David somebody
put me in a video game where they have
islamist throwing me off a roof with
Milo I I saw that yeah that's great
that's just great oh this is a good one
somebody said that Trump said in his
speech I will never let you down when I
heard that line I thought this is the
kind of crazy that he shouldn't be
doing like of course you're going to let
us down Jesus could be president would
let us down like it's just a bad move
but is that just like it's just words
it's just meaning
it's just a it's just an ending to a
speech like I think people are going to
forget about it in like a couple days
but I think writing that writing that in
in the script was probably a really dumb
move because it's like you've already
let people down you've already let
millions of people down like you can't
possibly make that like even Obama like
oh hey uh you gonna close Guantanamo
anytime
soon maybe later and it's like even he
let people down and he was like person
that everybody loved like even even I
who might not agree with Obama's
policies like guy dude was charismatic
like I can't even deny that dude yeah he
really likable is that the Obama Legacy
I mean that's kind of what I was
thinking the whole time it's like man
for whether you like Obama or not
whether you think Obamacare was good or
not whether you think the economy didn't
go off the cliff in 2009 because of him
all that his legacy in a weird way
is that Trump is now president he cannot
be happy about that yeah I guess I
didn't think about
that t what do you think you think
that's the that's the
Legacy uh I I think so you know in in
some respects I mean I I I and I will
you know give credit to Obama on this
one um you know he he did do a few good
things you know in regards to um um some
stuff you know Obamacare enforcing was
not one of them but um he he his his um
opening up to relations to Cuba his um
you know um getting osam Bin Laden for
whatever that's worth um and his um what
was the most recent his release of
Chelsea Manning not release but his um
um commutation of her sentence um that
was pretty good um but then he he
followed that by releasing a communist
terrorist who planted bombs across New
York city so I don't know but um but
yeah yeah his his legacy is going to be
you know the president that was cool you
know the cool Uncle who who didn't do
anything you know relatively useful or
you know incredible but you know he was
he was just fun to have around dinner
and
stuff yeah hey a bunch of people are
asking sort of the same question in
different ways but they kind of want to
know like what do you guys want out of
this like out of what you're doing is it
just to keep making videos and you know
go forward that way or do you want to be
picked up by a network you want to be TV
stars Chris you want to be a huge music
star you want to be in a video game like
what what's the what's the end game here
Chris you first um me I just uh I just
kind of want to grow the channel I don't
really care what the topic is that grows
it I just have fun doing video
production and working in this
environment meeting all sorts of cool
people uh it's it's been uh an
interesting ride but it's it's fun like
how I see it is this is um a way for me
to build uh a small Studio like where I
can get people to maybe like the end
goal isn't political commentary it's
just like oh I'm accumulating all this
equipment for maybe one day I'll I don't
know one day I'll make maybe make a
short movie or something whatever it's
like I went to film school so that's
really what I want to do I'd like to be
behind the camera and this is this whole
thing has just been a hobby that just so
happened to take off and that's that's
my only goal out of this I don't really
have any particularly lofty political
aspirations T give me something
lofty ah yeah you know um um that guy T
2020 of
course would you ever office huh would
you run for
office not not no I mean in 40 years
chance you have a chance now yeah anyone
anyone can be president now yeah the
stakes are off it can be anyone you know
hopefully hopefully it's not Brianna woo
but she's running for congress right she
is she is I haven't seen her um her ad
yet but um I'm looking forward to out is
it it's great watch it I would hope so
for the record to her credit uh she
reached out to us about coming on the
show and we agreed to do it we were
going to do it this week but our
schedule was a little nuts but we're
going to rebook it but I I would be
happy to talk to sure total uh total
credit to her there I I would would not
expect that yeah you guys know I'm
reaching out to these people all the
time and 90% of them won't talk to me so
that's definitely I remember I remember
I got a lot of um tweets about like oh
you're on the Ruben report he only
interviews people who agree with him but
it's
like I know what the circumstance you're
in it's like the people who disagree
with you either block you or just don't
want to come on yeah first off you know
yeah people block me right like I just
in the last week I tried to get that MTV
girl Chris that you've given a lot of
what's her name uh Francesca Ramsey
yeah I tried to get her on I was going
to Tweet her I saw that I was blocked I
was trying to get uh Ghostbusters girl
what's her name Lesley Jones G to
tweeted her I saw I was blocked but at
the same time I've had plenty of
progressives and lefties on and I treat
them with respect so people think that
they're not even here because I treat
them nicely I guess they want me to be
mean to them but but yes a lot of them
won't even talk to me just how it is
yeah yeah that's unfortunate and I I I
get I hear the same thing too um except
I feel like I feel like they come at you
from both sides um there's a side that
says uh you you only get um right-wing
people on you only get you know
Libertarians and conservatives and stuff
but then on the very far right um people
say ah he never has anyone right on he
always has these you know Centrist on
you know he he needs he needs like a um
like a millennial woes guy or something
like that he he needs he needs someone
who's going to tell him the the um you
know great um message um of the ethn
state you know isn't that the best
lesson of you just have to do what you
think is right like that's more if I
learned anything this year that was it
because you're right I get these people
that say I some some schmuck wrote an
article about me this week saying I'm a
white supremacist yeah I'm a white
supremacist meanwhile I have the the uh
alt-right people saying that I don't
even have real alt-right people on cuz
I've had you know Milo and cernovich but
I haven't had the true Neo-Nazi so it's
like you just got to do what you think
is
right yeah and and I feel like you're
doing that and um it's it's useful I
mean I I I enjoy how how you um present
your interviews and how you bring people
on how you you know just your your your
style of um interviewing where you just
you know ask people you know what they
think and then you let the audience
decide for themselves you're not really
trying to you know catch them in a lie
you're not really trying to press them
you know trying to say hi see you're
wrong or or you know or even trying to
gloat them like see oh see you're
wonderful you know it's just just let
them talk starting this week with this
new Skype thing we have we're our new
thing is we're going to be selectively
editing a lot of what you guys have said
today and pushing it out accordingly to
show that you're racist or islamophobic
etc etc that's why we have you guys in
Little Boxes
here yeah good I'll put it in now gas
the Puerto Ricans all of them including
oh no man I I wish Blair could have
joined us but we did the hour guys yeah
it's a shame Blair yeah now now
people are gonna think we're transphobic
or something right ah damn it yeah right
and before um end off um I guess I'll
switch it around and pose a question to
the um interviewer what um what's your
what's well of course what are your
plans going forward but um what do you
see happening in the realm of um you
know alternative media going forward how
do you think is going to play out and
what what are your plans in regards to
this Trump presidency and how you're
going to go about addressing it yeah I
mean I've said on the show a couple
times like my whole thing with Trump for
the last month and a half you know
basically since he got elected two
months now is that I couldn't go crazy
yet you know people are going crazy
about every pick and every tweet and all
that and it's like wait till he's
president so starting today if he starts
doing bad I'll call him out on that
but for the last two months I just
knowing the way he ran the campaign
where he was trying to get us all
outraged first I'm just not going to
play that game it's just not I'm I'm not
going to be that dumb basically the way
the rest of these media people are so
I'd say for the online thing and the
space that we're all in I think there's
huge things coming this year I I had a
couple interesting meetings in New York
I I think there's a lot of opportunity
for guys like us to be doing a lot more
together and I think that there's a huge
Awakening even from mainstream that they
actually need people like us now you
know nobody gives a about what's
happening on CNN right now except the
people that are on CNN it's just true
and I'm not pretending that the three of
us know everything or are experts in
every field but I know that you guys
offered more honest interesting
commentary than 90% of that cable
and I think that we're all
getting this to critical mass and it's a
kind of beautiful thing so uh so I've
got some plans we're we're right at the
beginning here you know how it is you
every time you move forward then you're
somehow back at the beginning again it
could be quite
exhausting yeah but but it's a
worthwhile ride of course yeah
absolutely and actually I will give a
little tease on this I have been
thinking about doing some a little bit
of a weekly news kind of thing where we
would incorporate this Skype thing get a
couple people all over the world and
maybe uh I'll have you two clowns
back sounds PR we did the exact same
head move that's pretty insane I like
that like how you guys synchronized the
head there I don't know what that meant
you like I don't know about that dang
man all right guys well good luck with
under a trump presidency I hope the
authoritarians don't come get you till
at least the end of the weekend and uh
and we'll do this again next time we'll
get Blair and couple other cool people
yeah yeah man it was it was it was a
good time yeah thanks for having me on
guys cheers all right see you guys later
[Music]